that's where I want to go next we do
have that voicemail number available to
you unlike live calls which are at a
specific time of day you can call the
voicemail number anytime you want and
many people do call it at very unusual
times which is fine you can even call
the voicemail number at the time that
we're taking live calls yes but you
can't call the live call number just at
any time that you want to that has to be
a specific time but make note of that
kids in case you weren't sure about that
we got a voicemail two one nine two
david p and it is from the Eggman and it
is about how he confronts people who he
sees littering out of their cars I do
I really like the environment and I do
not like people that litter and I'm
behind a car that with a cigarette butt
out of the window it gets me really
angry do you see this do you notice this
what do you do when you see this okay
this is what I used to do I used to say
people hey that's a nice car too bad it
didn't come with ashtrays or I asked
them hey do you have a sprays in that
car the responses I get are completing
ignoring me ranges from that to trying
to threaten my life and throw me into my
car tries to kill me so I don't know
what to do when I see somebody throwing
cigarette butts as a window of that call
yeah I want to shame them so they think
twice next time but sometimes they
either don't care or they try to further
right just look the other way
Salaam brother glad you're back yeah
Shalom yeah one of the things that I am
sort of hesitant to do is just confront
random people in public because you
don't know who's liable to just go
completely off the charts off the rails
and attack you but former producer Louis
does have the story of when he was
walking from the nearest subway station
to our studio where he saw a couple of
guys one of whom threw or like a I was
at like a Pepsi bottle or a coke can or
something like that or maybe one of
those like 64 ounces with a straw in
them and he went over to the guy and
confronted him and the guy actually
ended up picking it up and carrying it
with him and putting it in the nearest
nearest trash bin which I would not do I
admit I would not do that yeah
apparently Louis is a lot tougher than
we are I would just give him a dirty
look and call it a day at that yeah I do
have one story which I wouldn't do this
now but when I had first gotten my
license I was driving on the
Massachusetts Turnpike I believe between
exits the
for maybe four and five out in western
mass and someone pulled up I was in the
slow lane on the pike and someone came
around me on the left side it was two
young girls roughly my age you know 17
at the time something like that pull in
front of me and then they throw one of
those like 7-eleven big soda cups into
the straw out of the window and it hits
my windshield Oh No
and it was entering but still I said you
know I am gonna retaliate so I called
the state police and I said the person
in front of me just did this they said
really where where where are you driving
right now
I said I'm between exits four and five
they said you know what we got a trooper
right there don't follow them but just
stay on the highway and let's see if we
can get everybody together the trooper
pulled this brilliant move where he
somehow appeared got in between behind
the vehicle that had thrown the stuff
but in front of me put on their flashers
made it clear that he was not only
pulling over the people in front of me
who had done the littering but also
wanting me to stop so all three vehicles
pull over to the side cop comes up to me
he says what's going on I said they
threw this cop he said really that's
littering on a federal highway it's like
a five hundred dollar fine I don't you
you can go on your way I'm gonna deal
with them and I remember I wouldn't do
this now it was so vindictive but I
remember pulling out and just looking
over and sometimes two girls sitting
there miserable that somehow a state cop
showed up and now they were getting a
$500 ticket well that's a much better
solution than starting a fight with the
group of seventeen year old girls yes I
think you came away with flying colors
well that was a beta SOI boy at the time
so there was no way I was gonna actually
do the full confrontation so instead I
called the cops and that bad that's it I
wouldn't do that now I was you know at
the time I thought that there was
something cool about what I did imagine
getting fine like that for littering of
all things yeah we just that would ruin
my week listen littering has huge
externalities and people should be fined
for littering because it's causing a
huge environmental problem anyway I'm
ready for the hate about that story
we've got a great bonus show for you
today hope you'll join us become a
member or a patron to get instant access